since my wife and my baby couldn't be
here i thought it would be fun to at
least
use a picture so um i don't know if you
guys can tell that there aren't any blue
balls in the tub with presley
but we got baby girl number two on the
way
yeah so i need to get boy dogs or
something i know that's what yeah
isn't she cute look at her um she's
adorable
she's just learning how to take care of
her her little baby dolls so
maybe in july when when her sister comes
she'll be ready but yeah
baby baby girl yeah are you going to do
i'm trying for boy oh i don't know
okay i mean i guess you're not doing any
of it is she gonna keep trying i think
for me it's just the fun part so
um if if she gets through this labor the
first labor was actually pretty rough
oh my god um so you know you got to like
wrap your head around the idea of
another
and now she's having another so yeah i
think if it's rough again she's probably
done
if it's easier than the first one yeah
maybe man they kept telling me my second
one they were like oh that no way it's
gonna be like your first one was
hospitalized it was horrible
and then it was worse and i was like wow
you can go ahead and
remove those tubes
[Laughter]
yeah i don't need any of these anymore
it was about yep i'm still here just
waiting for you to subscribe
if you don't i'll be trapped in this box
forever